you've interviewed how many Mafia people
of that life I I don't know anybody that
I could I have yeah yeah where did you
this Interest come up in your life that
obviously a kid from Iran you weren't
watching the good you know Godfather no
but you did though oh did you mean
Godfather in Iran was like everybody
watched the god wow even in Iran in
Farsi okay yeah so yeah tell us about
that yeah so no we grew up watching that
we grew up watching all of that and then
you know uh Bronx Tale Carlito's Way
Scarface you add all of them up any one
of them good Fellas Casino there's a
level of curiosity you know what's
happening because everything in business
and in the mob it's very very similar
the only difference is if you cut
somebody they don't kill you they may
terminate your contract they may you
know no longer do business with you they
may do whatever they can to put you out
of business which is a form of a lawsuit
but they're not going to come and kill
you right but everything else
is very similar well you heard Pat talk
at the Vault I mean about systems about
discipline about uh organizational
structure I mean literally almost nobody
did it better culturally safety uh how
the level of respect with women certain
code you followed sisters daughters uh
uh what so that created a level of
safety if you were in right there was a
level of safety so if you create an
inner circle in your business in your
company those who are in it there's a
level of uh safety there's a level of
additional benefits that comes with that
there's a so that model is Ran by A lot
of different people in business so many
similarities and then you know Michael
and I uh there was a uh Bill McIntosh we
got to give him credit because Bill kept
saying Pat you got to interview Michael
I'm like uh Bill I'm not doing this he
says Pat I'm telling you interview
Michael for a year and a half bill from
Peru would follow me asking me to
interview Michael and I kept saying no
finally we agreed on my way to Michael's
house I was sitting with Jordan Belfort
in Manhattan Beach I tell Mario Marty
we're late to the next interview we're
supposed to be there like four or five
four Thirty or something we show up at 6
30. and they're supposed to go to a
church function so I'm like these guys
so Mario's hey Michael so sorry they're
on their way they're on their way I'm
dealing with LA traffic finally we get
there an interview that was never
supposed to happen at that time
Michael's you know we are we're I don't
know how many Subs we had at that time
500 450 000 some number like that right
and Michael doesn't have a lot of views
online he's got 500 000 view videos 300
000 view videos he's done some stuff
and then we do the interview
we post it we don't think much of it
next to Michael's like hey Patrick can
you tell me what's going on I said
Michael you're on the cover of world
star he says what are you talking about
so the interview goes our world start
picked up by Worldstar everybody starts
contacting us about this interview it
takes off now it's got I don't know 12
plus a million about to cross 13 million
views and uh and so that led to the next
interview and I don't know who I think
we did another part to you and I yeah we
got well over 20 some odd Millions oh
yeah yeah we I mean listen I mean now
Michael's got stuff that he did with bus
he's all over the place Michael is done
wired but I don't you got everything now
you got your channel that's about to
cross a million Subs you guys are
crushing it with your crew uh that you
guys got there then Sammy we did the
interview with Sammy and Sammy was uh
extremely difficult to get that done he
just didn't want to get on camera Sammy
didn't want to get on camera he says you
think I'm gonna sit with you I sat with
Diane Sawyer in 1994 I'm gonna do one of
these YouTube things
but talk about that how yeah
Apple Michael I don't I don't know
honestly it's it's the CRA you know
sometimes I'm in bed laying down at
night and I'm saying what am I doing
with this
you know it's a powerful tool man yeah
it is you know you know things got real
when you said if you like that there's
another clip over here and if you'd like
the Channel Please Subscribe and smash
that thumbs up what are we talking about
not only that I'm almost every other day
I go on YouTube and there's somebody
else yeah you know I mean it's like you
know it's a whole genre people go crazy
we're saturated it's really only two
people that are you know so of course
there is a lot but you know when it
comes down to this genre it's two people
I know John is thinking about doing this
rumor on the street is Janice thinking
about doing something uh so if no he is
doing something yeah I know he's a
woodchuck Mafia he's doing but I don't
know what angle he's gonna take I don't
know how he's got some people on his
team that are quality people we've had a
couple conversations with them in the
past not today when we did the Sammy
interview we had some exchange there but
uh it's not going to be a camp that's
going to have a lot of people there and
the Sammy's interviews now got 12 plus
million views so both of them 12 so you
got Sammy 12 plus million views Michael
12 plus million views he's about to
cross 13. now we have Mafia States of
America so it's not like individuals so
Sammy calls Michael out then Michael
calls Sammy out and it went back and
forth back and forth back and forth
non-stop like Michael would say
something and it's something but what
are you saying there what's your point
with that and then Michael Sammy would
say something but Sammy I disagree with
you and then they so you this like Chaz
Paul and Terry says Patrick I don't know
if you understand this this has never
happened in a history of uh of uh
uh Mob this has never happened so and I
got a phone call I got I'll tell you
about afterwards a very interesting
phone call that you and I will talk
about uh right after I was gonna bring
it up to yesterday there was too many
people around but I'll talk to you about
it afterwards what happened very strange
people have contacted me about this
interview because everybody wants to
know and then the trailer so now people
are asking when is this coming out you
know we don't have a date yet you know
we're trying to figure out when we're
going to launch it people wanted to come
out tomorrow it would drive me crazy
I don't know yeah speak to Patrick yeah
it's big it's bigger than than the mafia
genre though I mean this is this is a
history this is an America that doesn't
exist I think they're going to watch us
100 years they have to I mean this is a
time capsule this is the what I got out
of this and from the research that we're
doing from the project man is that that
this is the story of immigrants making
their way in America you could be the
mafia is identified with Italian
Americans but as we got into it you
talked about Bugsy Siegel we talked
about Jewish the the Jewish immigrants
in the in the beginning in New York with
ones that taught the other immigrants we
talked about this then there was the
Irish Westies and then the the attack
but nobody took it to the level of the
Italians did I mean the Russians and the
Chinese maybe but well no I'm going to
tell you this you know when you talk
about Mafia of course on oyster in this
country you gotta understand we survived
and prospered for almost 100 years under
some difficult conditions I mean we
always had law enforcement after us but
why because we had structure we had
discipline we had Authority and we had
respect among one another and and there
was some pretty intelligent guys there
you know I always say this you know you
know who made the mafia in this country
who gave us the biggest Advantage
prohibition the government yeah
prohibition because of prohibition
because that's when the money came in
that's when we started getting the money
and you don't do anything without money
and you were Advocates you were
advocates for the people at that point
the people didn't want prohibition you
were advocating for the public
absolutely yeah is there any
similarities to to today prohibition was
in the 20s right so now it's 100 years
later
are there any comparisons today to what
the government is doing to manifest a
certain Marketplace like is Bitcoin the
new prohibition it's like what's that
correlation because I have a Russian
friend who says when the government goes
we're talking about like government
overreach and tyranny and online and
everything like that he was like it's no
problem for Russians we just go black
market they can do whatever they want
Russians are very smart but you know uh
you don't want to get me started I'm
writing a book I want you to get
feedback Mafia democracy because I am
telling you that our government today is
acting very Machiavellian just like the
ideology that we followed on the street
and the other thing I wanted to say
remember all these other groups I mean
you got to give them credit but you know
you take the cartels in in uh you know
Mexico South America they're built
around drugs you take drugs away that's
it they got nothing but we infiltrated
every sector of society from the guy on
the street with the numbers business
right up to the White House and
everything in between and you you know
this Patrick you control the unions in
this country you control the country at
least today yeah that's literally what
the Democrats are not really right now
not today because they took a lot of the
Union power away from us but look you
control the teamsters you got two and a
half million truck drivers you call a
strike the country stops which you call
a strike at the Docks nothing comes in
and out to his point what did they just
do in Australia to uh to to compete
against these vaccine mandates the
truckers shut down the roads they
stopped on the bridges they at all at
the same time they shut the country down
and within 24 hours South Wales in
Australia went from mandatory
vaccinations to uh non-mandatory two
what do they consider well it was uh and
it's legit you call a strike it's legit
they can't do anything to stop you until
until you negotiate and they reach a
point of a conclusion but you have that
kind of power you know when politicians
you've got these huge Pension funds you
know politicians are drawn to money you
know that Patrick get drawn to money
when you control the that type of when
you have that type of control you've got
a lot of authority who has more power in
America than the Nea right now the
education it's funny yesterday I spoke
to Captain Dennis tager who is the
spokesperson for the largest Union for
pilots in America 15 000 Pilots it's
called APA Allied Pilots Association
right and he was talking about uh uh uh
the difference between union today
versus before you know how Jimmy Hoffa
Union before versus today how different
is today's Union than before has it
changed much or is it still similar kind
of influence and power good question
it's changed a lot because the mob
doesn't have the control over it as it
did before okay you know and the numbers
are down in the unions numbers are down
I think you know back you know in my day
unions were powerful man we look I had
when you say numbers are down you mean
percentage of Americans who are part of
Union one out of as lead as the 1960s
one out of every three Americans was in
a union and now I gotta suspect it's
less intense you know so it's no but
because it's it's uh forty percent
because almost 90 percent of all
government employees are unions there's
almost no private sector unions they're
all public sector now Patrick I had
control through a guy by the name of
Danny Cunningham we had the um uh
security Union right we had we had
security at nine nuclear power plants in
the country
now in those nuclear power plants I
don't know if you know at that time when
a nuclear plant closed down you had to
have security there for a hundred years
what a hundred years 100 was closed why
that's what the government said you got
to have security there for a hundred
years so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]